so how often do you guys get together
and hang out not often enough and we do
we do quite a bit actually but every
time I see him I feel like we need to do
it more we could hang out some does it
feel like a reunion when you do stuff
like this no no if we had more of us
here probably okay so when you guys are
together how much of the time I man do
you ever have conversations about nine
or to 102 ever just sit around and
reminisce no no it's all new what well I
don't know I mean I can speak for myself
I'm spent a lot of time look in the rear
view mirror yeah as you well know like
young man how many times have you guys
we're never talking about stuff that
happened 20 years ago we're talking
about what all the stuff I'm doing now
yeah probably crash when did you when
did you get coke as I remember and you
just brought this up I'm years and years
and years ago the rule was no questions
about 90 to 100 then it was maybe one
question about 90 to 100 then it was
don't dwell on I know - I know and now
we're doing a panel with the two of you
where everything is sort of good you're
writing it but when did you get cool
with the legacy well I think that you
know III think that I immediately when
you come off a show like that I think
you try to distance yourself from from
you know an iconic show like that where
you played an iconic character I think
you try to give yourself a little
distance from that right out of the gate
then you know as a little time goes by
and people start to forget about that a
little bit then you can sort of let that
those sorts of questions and let that
kind of conversation start to creep back
into it and then and that's just the way
it is but out of the gate I think you
got to try to get a little distance from
those kinds of things yeah do you like
Dylan did you like the guy of all the
characters on the show that's the one I
would have wanted to play yeah yeah
would you have been his friend
yeah I would have tried yeah yeah yeah
would you Ben Brandon's friends know on
a beat that's not out of that guy
sanctimonious prick that he was like
when do you realize oh my god I am an
actor because I'm playing somebody that
is so not even remotely me is it his
sort of a case like that that's when you
realize how good of an actor you are
well that I mean that's that's what
being an actor is that that's what you
do I mean you take on you take on
personas that are not your own which is
which is why you do what you do Yeah
right there was a lot of issues that you
guys did in that show that really helped
a lot of people grow up it opened up a
lot of conversations between kids that
watch the show and and parents was there
something you did on that show that
you're still sort of like I can't
believe we did that and got away with it
when they had me driving in the car
smoking heroin yeah I just thought that
that was a little much
in reality you know heroin is a problem
in that demographic you know and it was
starting to become so but that for me I
remember I remember doing the shot where
I had to have the cameraman sitting on
the back of the car shooting over my
shoulder so you could see that I was had
it in my hand and what I was doing and
also that the car was moving you know to
sort of heighten the danger on them and
I remember thinking wow this is crazy
this this doesn't seem like a shot for
our show you know it hold the heroin
pipe up a little now get the flame under
it now you know and I thought Babs
doesn't seem like Nana do I know yeah
would you be able to do that on TV now
do you think I'm a fan on Iran what is
considered a family show I'm blown away
I'm surprised it will get up by now on
TV and a f30
you know in primetime and half our shows
other shows I yeah it would get over
today yeah it definitely would I mean
our standards and practices are a lot
more relaxed now than they were then I
mean think you know when you were doing
that you could see you get I'm sure they
could see the the lighter cooking the
hair and stuff but you couldn't see you
actually inhale the smoke you know what
I mean there's a lot of rules around the
stuff you know I directed a lot of the
episodes where and when
Kelly and Jason Wiles his character when
they were doing you know when they were
doing all the cocaine they were doing
all the stuff and they were a lot of
rules about you know you could see the
cocaine and you could see them chopping
it you could see their heads go out if
you'd hear them syrup you couldn't
actually see them snort it like oh yeah
there's a there were a lot of rules and
regulations and things and and that's
that's how you get a run so you had to
come up with creative ways to get around
those things and I think that you know
the the heroin smoking thing the weight
the way you're talking about the
director shot it you know that was a
really creative way to get around the
rules that standard practices put on
those things I'm reading an article last
week about Justin Bieber he was in a
hotel had to get at the hotel so they
put him in a laundry bin and then I'm
reading an article about you guys in
like 91 where you were in a mall people
got hurt had to get you out they put you
in a laundry bin yeah yeah I so what was
what are you saying is you were the
Justin Bieber of 1991 how does that make
you feel real good did you at that point
did you think maybe I'm all happy in
laundry bins and all I thought was my
cars over there yeah there are 20,000
people between me and it the best way
for me to get there now Missy is for me
to jump in you piled on top of me the
jumpiness think you pile that stuff on
top of me and let's just go yeah and I
never intended it to be it just there
happened to be a bin there I jumped in
it threw the stuff on
she just started pushing that was back
in the days when they they would ask us
to go to shopping malls and make
appearances yes we would do right after
that that they stopped doing enough that
and after that happened shopping malls
were off-limits for for all of us for
years I didn't set foot inside a
shopping mall because that's where
teenage girls would congregate to hang
out verboten what is your what did what
is your relationship with Fame now
do you hate it have you hated it have
you kindly give it that kind of power
that kind of energy I think I'm coming
turns it exists it's in the you know
it's it's on the table I know but I
you just don't wake up thinking about it
yeah the level of Fame that I have now
is is perfect it's pretty it's perfect
because I can because I can go about my
normal life and and everything is cool
but if I need to but if I need to get a
table at the French Laundry I can I can
do it yeah
which is perfect